hey guys I'm Ryan right yes yes all
right
look who I got on the channel until you
guys helped out so thank you guys soon
you guys had some [ __ ] up [ __ ] during
though I wish you didn't got her
attention especially when you're giving
death threats and calling her a stupid
piece of [ __ ] you yeah good job yeah
yeah you can't believe you said that
there come on move you were really nice
sir thank you very much for the
encouraging words only a few only a few
but yeah Dell has her own YouTube
channel called roll credits and she's a
great critic I actually watch her
channel like I watch a lot of her
reviews yeah I love your hair you have
like really pretty curly hair like a
shaggy dog like a shaggy that's cool
found out though she has a boyfriend
total [ __ ] such [ __ ] otherwise I
totally have a chance
good good you watching buddy cuz I'm
about to Ryan my right in whatever that
means I don't know anyway guys we're
gonna watch the trailer day for the
strain it's a television show produced
by you did he create it too I don't
really know much about it but I know
it's a horror show and all I know is
that it's got those big billboards off
down on Sunset of a giant eye with a
woman in the eye and coming bloody and
veiny and looks cool lovely
yeah Guillermo del Toro's involved in it
I love Guillermo del Toro's films that
was a fan of Pacific Rishi Pacific time
yeah did you like it yeah for what it
was I was pretty impressed by the
effects yeah like that was impressed I
just I expected a little bit more
character out of a guillermo del toro
movie right cuz that's that's what he
tends to really get down it's like an
interesting adventure along with great
character but you didn't do it this is
so weird you're here I feel like I'm
meeting a celebrity this is so awkward
for me it's like you watch someone's
videos so much and then like suddenly
you're like I'm in front of them it's a
surreal experience your boyfriend but
yeah [ __ ]
see way it looked a lot that's okay so
the trailer I downloaded is it's only 30
seconds long I hope this is the right
one before some of you guys really hate
on me for watching the wrong one but
let's hope you haven't seen any before
then yeah that's what counts shut-ins me
keep it short and sweet
short and sweet I've seen this disease
before passengers must destroy
strean Sunday July 13 on FX yeah looks
really freaky I got like chills right
here and here I don't know why my body
is only responding it looks great
actually like I love a good show with
great effects in it then actually
amplify the experience of a television
show yeah man and it looks scary looks
genuinely scary yes I will be watching
this show with the lights turned on keep
away the monsters I'll be watching
that's cool no I'm really excited for
the show 2d watch a lot of FX shows yeah
she's from Austria I don't really know
how to differentiate the channel there's
a sniper shows how long have you been in
America again a year and a half a year
and a half but I don't have television
isn't that an accent so hot it's just so
you could get so many guys with just
that accident you should really consider
your options right now I do speak a lot
say yeah no it's beautiful I could hear
your voice all day long Adele all night
long I think about your voice often when
times are rough it's my heart and my
soul sorry I was just trying to make you
feel more comfortable because it's your
first time on the show so couch yeah my
bouncy velvet couch yeah you will see
the couch on the camera there like it
looks so comfortable but it's really an
uncomfortable I know well that was the
plan and it hasn't gone into fruition
yeah I was hoping to work my magic today
I know gosh what is the point of all
this work idea anyway guys yeah thanks
for letting me know that trailer was out
I was already planning on watching it
before I even saw a clip of this because
I really you know it has like I'm not
sure this is about has like a zombie
feel and vampires of infection yeah and
I like a good horror movie do you watch
a lot of work I prefer real ihara not
just gold bloody horror
absolutely what are some of your
favorite thriller Horrors watching penny
dreadful which was a Showtime TV show
just finished up last week and had a
little bit of Farah not too hardcore
Hara but it had some demons and exorcism
type of stuff in 18th century London
very cool yeah you're the main reason I
go on YouTube now if you're new to the
channel you can click this button up
here to subscribe to subscribe to
Adele's Channel roll credits you can
click this button right here what am i
can I get your autograph
ok I got a photo of me with it's just me
in a speedo and I could totally sign
that for you it'd be great if I could
get a similar photo from you ok and oh
Adele will you help me do some shout
outs real fast I would be on it ok
ok cool was there any one specific thing
you wanted to shout out well yes IFS he
wanted to quickly shout out nixon next
her name's Nicole and she's the first
person who introduced me do Jenna oh
yeah another pretty awesome yeah I can't
do an Australian just sound like an
[ __ ] ok mate good night
really sound like I'm mocking you guys
good good guy my what else did you guys
say what's a popular stereotypical cry
gay
just yesterday I said far out yeah I was
surprised by something can you do an
American accent why do people always ask
you that now I can you really can't know
I feel like you'd be able to pull it off
one day maybe we can work on it we can
work on it your boyfriend's I know
better
yeah naked next I like Nikki next a lot
she's really cool I'm very familiar with
her actually I've seen a lot of her
video see she has trailer reactions as
well
if fron moogle on June 25th he asked
this hey Ryan today is my birthday June
26th
from you in the gang sorry the gangs not
here but at Del's here hot ah see that's
what counts
sorry a friend yeah but still happy
[ __ ] birthday man how old are you you
can't answer me right now cuz this video
is gonna be posted over by lappers
shooting it if fraud you don't have a
display picture so we can't guess but
yeah hit front that's a cool name are
you like
Irfan my bad I said your name wrong
Irfan yeah cool name dude very cool you
could be like the first Arabic superhero
with that kind of name unless it's a
very common name then you should change
your name I would want the ability to
seduce any woman without having to work
at all for you okay yeah yeah girls be
like huh I was hoping out having a day
but the AK spray does not help so mr.
optimist two four seven if you gave me a
shout-out tell me which video I'll see
if I can remember they contacted yeah
you just watch the videos man look for
the shoutout well mr. optimist are you
going after Optimus Prime is it Optimus
like you're optimistic Oh which one is
it 2024 set always mr. optimus 24/7 what
oh you're like on a bad day gosh man or
if you like don't have sex for a while
and where you're like you just really
aggravated and frustrated and transforms
transforms into [ __ ] Incredible Hulk
at that moment and then just the next
Transformers will just feature regular
toy
often miss Prime's a Toyota Camry James
Stevens he wanted a shout-out on the
transformers age of extinction review I
don't do shoutouts on those reviews but
he said that he loves my videos and he
wants me to keep up the great work and
don't worry man I won't let you down I
will constantly keep up the great work
and do my best to keep bringing
beautiful woman like her
channel and that's why yes yes I get
afraid to look at you in the eyes for
too long it makes me uncomfortable yeah
yeah probably have a heart attack or
something I look at you in the eyes and
I'm like [ __ ] you're making eye contact
with me
and then that's like you have a hard
time making eye contact with you all I
really do people think I do but most of
the time it's it's such a focus like
right now those little [ __ ]
it's a it's a focused effort for me to
make eye contact with people and I get
so focused on the fact that I'm making
eye contact that I'm not listening on my
head really Wow yeah so if I remember
making eye contact with you assume I'm
having a hard time listening but anyway
back to you James Stevens that sounds
like it could be like a 1950's like
detective named detective Stevens are
you doing that kid then yeah Adele
walked into my office she was having
trouble with her boyfriend her hair was
as blonde as Sun legs as long as a
giraffe's neck you gotta work on your
detective skills dodging detective
Stevens all right cool